so good morning everyone really pleased
to be back here in the UK again at
another PI data a London event I think
this is my third so that's really
exciting
so I'm also happy to be here today's
talk about bouquet so as Emily mentioned
I'm I've been working on bouquet for a
long time and it's certainly something
that's near and dear to my heart so I
love talking about it and sharing it
with people so quick show of hands Acts
I guess who has already seen bouquet or
use bouquet at all okay okay good so
definitely wanted to make sure to cover
some new stuff in this tutorial that
hasn't maybe been presented before but
I'm gonna go ahead and sort of go
through just the very beginning of this
tutorial fairly quickly as well we'll go
at a pretty good clip so if you want to
participate if you want to actually try
things out basically all of the
tutorials are in notebooks and so you
can either go to this n be viewer link
right here and the static rendered
notebooks are there you can download
them and run them locally on your laptop
or if you want to prefer you can just
clone the github repository for the
notebooks and there's a tutorial
directory in there so maybe we'll give
everyone just a couple of minutes to get
set up and if anyone has any questions I
can certainly come out and take a look
hopefully everyone has you know anaconda
be the easiest way to get started you
have anaconda installing that's the the
recommendation they made for everyone
you should be set up with bouquet let's
take a look the version you're gonna
want is version 0.1 hopefully everyone
can see that I'm gonna do on the list
okay here and sure enough I have zero
point eleven point one sorry is the
latest release
we should mention as everyone's getting
set up that we are gonna have a 0.12
release I believe next month and haven't
really stated this before publicly but
the intention is that the zero twelve
release is actually the last pre 1.0
release so we should be having a 1.0
coming out pretty pretty soon later this
year so it's very excited about that and
I'll talk a bit about some of that at
the end maybe definitely gonna try to
leave some time for questions at the end
okay
so except everyone just a couple of
minutes once you have either the
notebooks downloaded from this link or
you know the the github repository
cloned well we'll go ahead and start if
anyone's have any problems just raise
your hand I'll come come take a look
and let's take a look at what those look
like so if you go to the NB viewer site
just the top interviewer site you'll see
there's a nice link to the the bouquet
sort of index page for NB viewer and
then down here there's tutorial and it
just says to start with the tutorial
introduction so just as a reminder on NB
viewer these are all static sort of
renderings of notebooks they aren't
notebooks you can actually run so you'll
want to download there is a download
link here and that'll work pretty well
there's a couple of exercises here that
rely on some separate Python modules
that are in that github repository so
that's gonna be the the best way to get
things but this is this will be good for
ninety ninety-five percent of everything
if you just want to download the
notebooks from here and so just to give
a quick overview as everyone gets set up
we're gonna go through as many of these
sections as we can again I'm gonna
probably go through a pretty fast clip
through some of the first sections so
we'll start off talking about some of
the high level charts also the sort of
ok top plotting sort of basic plotting
interface we'll talk about how you can
do all kinds of styling visual
attributes so there's all kinds of
things you can sort of configure and
style we'll spend some time talking
about layouts and widgets and
interactors and how you can add those to
even standalone documents we'll talk
about some ways that you can share an
embed bouquet plots we'll also talk a
little bit about the bouquet model
system which is sort of the foundation
of everything actually what ties the
client library book ajs together with
Python library there's some new
annotations that are available in okay
so we'll talk about that well let's talk
about some some ones that are coming up
in the next release and then really I
want to make sure to get to today's book
applications so for folks that might
remember or that have used bouquet for a
while we had a sort of a bouquet server
concept for for awhile and and you know
we learned some things from the original
iteration of that and ultimately we
found that it sort of wasn't
satisfactory and so we basically RER
connected it with a lot of help from
some fantastic people include including
havoc Pennington you may know from the
gnome and gtk world he came and helped
us out with that and the new server is
really amazing and fantastic and and I
think the sort of proof is in the
pudding so to speak it is because we've
seen a lot of people using it to do
really interesting sort of applications
and so we'll talk about that quite a bit
and then just a few extra topics in
actually I'm also going to talk about
the data shader project which is a
separate sort of project under the book
for dealing with larger datasets I'll
give you sort of a quick demo of that we
only have time to go into detail today
okay so I was gonna go ahead and get
started talking about the first notebook
any questions or comments or problems
before we before we just dive in well so
everyone's here for a nice lovely
morning it's a bit early
not too early yet it's pretty late for
me okay so actually first time I opened
up this intro notebook just to sort of
show you know show things off so what is
bouquet if you aren't familiar with it
it's a library for visualization it's
targeted at modern browsers for
presentation you wanna be able to have a
versatile sort of graphics that can
really be attached to sort of data in a
very natural way we want to be able to
let me make this bigger that's better
we want to only handle streaming data
maybe large data sets we're really
heavily focused on our bindings a
continuum is what we sort of worked on
but there's actually binding is now in
Scala and our tripod we're focused on
Python bindings but there's also
bindings now for our and Scala and some
giulia bindings that maybe need a
maintainer but it's really exciting it
is possible to create these language
bindings for booking but the main thing
of course is that you really don't have
to write any JavaScript we want to let
people create these visualizations in
the browser without having to dive in to
you know JavaScript and d3 and CSS and
HTML and lots of other you know
JavaScript libraries of the day so
bouquet is all about being able to do
that at high level from Python you know
in the language you already familiar
with that you're already using to be
productive with other tools okay so what
can you do with okay that's sort of what
it is what can you do with it well you
can do a lot of things here in the
notebook so you can create fairly
complicated charts in the exploratory
data analysis sort of way from one line
right so we have some data we want to
create some histograms from it it's just
a one liner so bouquet does have this
very high-level interface that's
available you can use to create
histograms and box plots and horizon
charts and the chord graph was just
added by a new contributor and all kinds
of so these are in tend to be very quick
very easy to get started with there a
lot of them are very focused around the
data frame and so this is that bouquet
that charts interface and so here's just
a just an example of that we'll dive
into some details in a second other
things you can do with bouquets you can
create really we've sort of web-ready
interactive visualizations that are very
nicely styled and nicely themed right so
this is a reproduction
this Hans ricing example that you know
shows the fertility rate versus life
expectancy over a number of years and so
you can have this nice slider and you
can scrub it and you can see you know
the data change and respond to me when I
scrub that slider this is a not a server
app this is just basically a standalone
HTML document you could email this to
someone it would work fine and we'll see
how to create some things like that in a
second
I just once I got this open up in Safari
which isn't good let me open this up in
chrome so we do have an issue with WebGL
and Safari we're still working through
but if I open this here in chrome should
be able to see things render pretty well
so we do have some WebGL support we
support sort of circles and lines right
now so if you want to be able to get
into sort of a slightly more medium data
size sets you can handle those with
bouquet as well let's get this to load
there we go there we go
well sure why that isn't showing up okay
well we'll have to come back to that
WebGL we're still working on that's a
pretty new feature but lastly that the
main thing is and then someone to talk
about today is creating these data
applications right where you could have
widgets and interaction selections that
are tied to Python code that can inform
you know further computations maybe you
want to do some machine learning
algorithms or some numpy or sci-fi
calculations based on some selections or
on some sliders you can do that with
bouquet and so you know here we have an
example of that this is actually running
on bouquet demo plots org so I'm here
over conference Wi-Fi and I'm able to
use this just fine so this is this is a
this absent embedded in an iframe here
in this notebook so it works I think by
having a pretty nice architecture that's
very decoupled so basically we have a
set of models in Python some objects
that represent all the things you might
want to put in your visualization
widgets or layouts sliders AXYZ grids
you know glyphs all of these things have
an object that represents them those get
serialized to JSON they get moved over
to the client in the browser in this
case and a completely identical object
model object graph is created inside the
client and that's really powerful
because in particular you can have other
languages like R or scholar or Lou or
Julie or whatever create that same JSON
and they can all drive okay plots in the
browser as well which is we've seen
people do but it's also really powerful
when you connect this with the bouquet
server because these different optic
graphs can be kept in sync so if you
make a change in the Python side that's
automatically reflected into the browser
if you make a change like a selection or
a widget you know manipulation in the
browser that change can get reflected
back to the Python as well and so this
sort of feedback loop is very powerful
okay and we'll see some examples of that
so getting set up you know you can run
this code at the bottom you should see
something fairly similar I've got sort
of ipython 4.2 and looks like pandas
0.17 although I think the newest version
of pandas just came out maybe a couple
of days ago and again this tutorial now
is sort of geared for bouquet zero point
eleven point one so pause just for a
second and sees anyone have any problems
getting set up everyone yes question
named what oh um so you should yeah so
there was something that Shane oh so you
have an older person tube okay I think
is my guess yeah I believe that sake so
there was a change that moved things
there and so if that import fails and I
think you have a verse the book is older
than zero point eleven so just try to
try that first and I'll come by during
the next exercise take a look
any other questions comments okay well
let's go ahead and charge forward will
go through will go through the charts
all right so charts that ipy and be oh I
don't actually want to do this on and be
viewer I want to do this on a real live
notebook right in front of me so I could
one of the things that's really nice
about bouquets we have added this
bouquet dot charts a very high level
interface recently it sort of the newest
interface to the youngest sort of member
of the bouquet API and so it's undergone
some sort of some experimentation and
evaluation I think we finally settled
down to sort of a framework that we like
we have new contributors adding new
charts now and I'm really excited about
this for the future I think it's gonna
be a lot of you know expressive
capability it's opened up but let's take
a look at some couple of kind of charts
that are very common so first thing is
you might want a scatter plot so we have
some data here so built into data are
built into bouquet is this this data set
the iris data set and by the way if you
need to download this data set the way
you can do that is this I mean searches
cell above so a few imports okay and
then okay
sample data dot download I don't
actually want to run this cuz I've
already got it downloaded but that's
what you would do this phone bigger as
well so execute that bouquet dot sample
data download that will download all the
sample data set for you might need okay
but anyways we've got this iris data set
we're gonna take a look at it so the
first thing we do is we execute this we
look at our data frame and we say sure
enough it's just got a couple of columns
about these species of flowers I think
there's four different species three
different species and they're
measurements for the the sepal length
and the petal length and the petal width
of all these different flowers and so
you can sort of take a look at that in
different ways and so let's take a look
at it with a scatter chart so we import
the scatter chart and then it's just a
single line right so we tell it you know
what column do we want to represent the
x coordinate in this case petal length
what column do we want to represent the
y coordinate this case pebble width and
sure enough we get a chart out but we
need to execute the lines up here we get
a chart out that has all that data and
so maybe that's what you want and that's
fairly you know straightforward we could
sort of one line but we might want to
actually do things like sort of color
the markers by some other field and so
we can do that very easily in this case
we can say something like color equals
species down here and now when we get
the chart it's going to actually do that
and now all the different species are
colored according to you know their
value we also get a nice legend up here
automatically as well so again that's
the whole idea behind this high level
charts interface is that it's really
supposed to be very quick it's not the
interface you might use to build like a
highly polished sort of web application
with but it's great in the notebook it's
great for sort of very fast usage okay
let's go ahead and take a quick exercise
give you guys just a couple of couple of
minutes to do this so we want to go
ahead and pass a column name as the
marker keyword argument in this in this
example here we can see what happens if
we also do that so just go ahead and
start from this line and paste it into
the cell here if you're running locally
and so we've got marker equals species
I'm going to go ahead and do marker
equals species again so we're going to
both color and specify a marker
according to the species column and sure
enough now you can see that not just
color has varied but also the markers so
we have circles for setosa and squares
for versicolor and triangles for
virginica so that's a really easy way
again to sort of get things out so you
don't have to do a lot of effort to get
this kind of sort of fascinating your
data according to the different
dimensions and we should be increasing
this even even more so we're working on
some really nice layout capability now
so well I have the ability to sort of
facet and have multi plots according to
these dimensions as well I'll give
everyone just a minute to try that out
if you have any problems having a run
just let me know so that scatter again
very high-level intended to be just sort
of useful for exploratory data analysis
getting started very quickly bar charts
another really common sort of chart
let's take a look at that with this Auto
mpg data set so here we have this Auto
mpg data set it's again it's a data
frame a lot of the charts are very data
frame centric so here we've got some
columns that represent things like miles
per gallon I know miles is a very
ridiculous unit cylinder is displacement
horsepower weight all these things for
different cars and so we want to be able
to shows maybe some of this data using
bar charts let's take a look so the way
bar works it is it you have a label and
that's gonna be what labels the x-axis
it's going to group the data according
to this this dimension and then values
and these are the values another column
and you want to aggregate over these
values and then of course you give it
the aggregation you want to do so let's
see a concrete example in this case we
give the label cylinder the values are
miles per gallon and the aggregation is
max so what that gives us is a charts
that is the maximum mpg by cylinder and
sure enough down at the bottom we have
it labeled by cylinder here's the
maximum RPG mpg for each group of
cylinders so that's nice as far as it is
but we can go ahead and do other things
as well like let's say we want to do
grouping you know we've got we've got
sort of a nice simple chart here we
might want to do grouping and so there's
this origin field in the data which I
gather is maybe a manufacturer I'm not
exactly sure what that is but there's
whatever it is we don't want to group by
that origin field and so we can just
pass in a group parameter and so we want
a group by origin and then if we execute
this sure enough we get a nice grouped
bar chart and so again because we've
done that automatically we get a nice
legend out that explains you know what
each different color means and so this
one by the way is by year so here we've
we've labeled it by year so it's miles
per gallon the
group by origin so this is the median
miles per gallon by year and then it's
grouped by origin so that's a nice
example so we can take this example and
for the next exercise we can go ahead
and modify this as well so there's also
a stacked parameter and so I'll let you
all that everyone here sort of modify
that will take a minute or two and let
everyone play around with that to modify
this example to get a stacked bar chart
instead of a group one
so at the end of day you should end up
with a chart looks pretty much like that
that's a good question
right now I don't know if there is a lot
of control that you can do with that but
that would be a great feature and it
probably would be very hard to add so we
can we can talk about that in detail but
yeah so we've actually recently added
some folks came in and asked about being
able to order some other things and some
different charts and so we were able to
respond to that and I think actually
maybe a new contributor came in and
helped out with that so these kind of
feeding there's a lot of features so you
know except charts to sort of the newest
API there's a lot of features that we'll
want to add to you know people just to
point them out but yeah so that's that's
a good question okay so again hopefully
I'm gonna has a chance to execute this
so again XE first another question who's
familiar with the notebook or who's not
familiar with the ipython notebook
almost everyone here okay you have any
questions let me know
you know notebooks pretty awesome it's a
nice way to sort of get get started
quickly okay so here I took the line
that I had before the the bar chart for
the auto mpg data again I labeled it by
year I want to aggregate over the miles
per gallon along at the median for every
year but I also want to sort of stack it
by origin so I want to break the bars up
into you know different so sub
components by origin so I have that
stack equals origin parameter that I
passed and that gives me this nice
stacked bar chart and I change the title
as well okay another pretty common chart
to want to use is a histogram right so a
histogram lets us take a series of data
we want to get sort of a sense or a feel
for what the distribution of values is
for this data and so histogram let's do
that so we have a built in histogram and
polka dot charts that we can use it very
quickly to get started so kind of
creating a synthetic data set for this
case it's a little bit weird I'm
basically stacking two sets of a
thousand values together one is a
thousand values picked from a normal
distribution another is a thousand
values pick from a log normal
distribution this is just for
demonstration purposes but you can take
a look at the data if we look at the
data frame we can see sure enough
there's you know the first thousand are
from this normal distribution the second
thousand from log normal we've just
labeled each each value with which
disturb you
came from so we can import histogram
from polka dot charts and then again
it's very data frame centric I just say
I want to Instagram of this data frame
the values is the column that I want to
actually do the histogram over I want 30
bins nope actually need to evaluate my
actually to run the cells above first
and then we do that we get a nice
histogram right so it's gonna take a
little bit of time to actually compute
computer histogram and we get the
histogram out and sure enough so this
looks a little bit maybe weird right
because this is actually a histogram of
all the values which is comprised of
both you know there's normal and this
log normal distribution so you can sort
of see that it's it's kind of strange
there or mean it is what it is but so we
might want to actually create multiple
histograms so this is the exercise there
is a there is a parameter in here go
ahead and make this comment here there
is a type parameter here that we can add
to histogram
and it will give us multiple histograms
so at this point I'm actually going to
refer everyone to the documentation as
well do you have a lot of documentation
up on boquete top height org so let me
go ahead and point everyone there so
that when you're doing exercises you
have some idea of where you can sort of
get more information so if you go the
users guide we have quite a lot of
information on our user's guide they
make that font a little bit bigger and
in this case we might want to navigate
to the high level charts section and so
if we go there we can see a lot of sort
of actually information sort of like
conceptual information about charts and
data frames we can also see things about
for instance bar charts and box plots
box plots histograms I'll be adding more
to that later so this is where you might
want to go to sort of get more
information about how to style and theme
and change lots of different colors
right so anyway in this case you can see
that the value that we want to do to get
multiple histograms by color is this
color field we give it a column for what
we want and that will so if we do color
equals type now we actually get a
histogram for each of the groups right
so basically we say color equals type
what that means is look in the type
column which again says normal or log
normal normal and group them according
to what the values there are so there's
two groups one for the normal
distribution one for the log normal
distribution and generate separate
histograms for both of those
automatically right so this allows us to
do things very quickly so I can I'll
give everyone just a just a little bit
of time to play around with that
it's add a legend to it as well in this
case I just tell it where I want the
legend to go legend equals top left and
it'll put it up here in the top left
yep questions so he got grouped and sack
I expect that there's an issue with
grouping and stacking together so try
just oh because he grouped and stacked
by origin okay interesting
so it's stacked them but it's also
grouped by origin so if you maybe give
it different yes that's actually very
interesting I would love for you to make
an issue with that that's something that
we could either warn about or I mean
it's kind of a it's kind of a
combination doesn't make sense to both
group and stock by the same field and so
we could probably just attack that it
say hey this is kind of a weird thing to
do but that actually it makes sense to
me why I did that but it's also you know
not useful to do that so okay cool
okay so last section here any other
questions before I finish up a quick
review of charts okay last section here
is box plot so again we want to go ahead
and import our box plot from polka dot
charts box plot if you're not familiar
is another way to represent sort of
distributions of data right and so we'll
take a look at one so here we're gonna
use that flowers data set again I want
to label by the species and for every
species I want to look at a box and
whispers whiskers chart for the petal
width and so we can go ahead and do that
and sure enough for every species down
there on the x-axis I've got this box
and whiskers chart that represents the
distribution of data for that particular
species right so this is the petal width
and millimeters and can sort of see that
all the species have pretty different
characteristics you know for their petal
widths at least I've given a color
parameter here I've given it this sort
of nice dark red color I like but it's
also possible to have it color them you
know by the species itself automatically
right so if I go ahead and copy this and
just for the sake the sake of time I'm
gonna go ahead and just do this exercise
if I say color equals species and I gave
it a column name here in the data
oh just type that if I give it species
then it'll actually give a different
shade of color to each of the box and
whiskers charts and we could add a
legend as well if we wanted to let's go
do that legend equals top left and so
now we actually get a legend that tells
us what those different colors which
species they correspond to so again
there's a lot of other or there's
several other charts that we aren't
going to cover here just for time there
is a horizon charts there is again this
new chord chart that was just added for
sort of visualizing different networks I
mean if we go to the users guide and the
docs and we go up into actually sorry
the reference guide we can go to polka
dot charts and we can see a lot of
different types of charts here there's
sort of an area chart and all the
reference guide has nice examples and
all of these as well there's an area
chart there is the box box plot there's
this sort of circular sort of donut
chart heat maps as well as our horizon
chart that I mentioned there's no line
charts scatter time series step charts
as well so again all of these are here
and have a nice documentation I
encourage you to check those out we're
gonna go ahead for now and move on from
charts just for the sake of getting to
some some new material okay so that is
close all these little notebooks that is
charts the next notebook we're gonna
take a look at is this zero to basic
plotting interface so any quick
questions before we start this section
said I'm going to sort of tear through
this this material sort of review
material pretty quickly
okay so there's another interface it's a
little bit lower level than polka dot
charts yeah it's called bokade
applauding and it's you know I would
characterize it as roughly the level of
sort of verbosity of you know matplotlib
or MATLAB or something like that the
idea is that you can very easily get
sort of a default chart a default plot
it has axes and grids and things like
that this would make sense for default
and then you can throw glyphs at it
throw shapes at it you've any kind of
sort of visual object you want you can
sort of throw that scatter that across
the plot and you can attach the
attributes of those visual objects to
the data directly alright so you might
want to have circles and you want to
vary the radius by some field and the
color of the outline color or the fill
color
the Phil alpha by all different fields
you have this kind of control to do that
so again we're in the notebook we're
going to import output notebook so that
we can see things there we're gonna
import this show function and figure as
well and so we load bouquet in the
notebook we can see that it's loaded
what is this bouquet dot plotting
interface look like well the the main
thing we start with is this called a
figure make this a little bit bigger
font so we we call figure in this case
we can also tell it we want a specific
plot with and plot height and then we're
gonna call circle and we can pass actual
lists or arrays have data to it a little
bit later on we'll see that we can pass
what's called a column data source to it
as well but in this case we're just
gonna pass literal lists of data for the
x coordinate the y coordinate we're
giving it a fixed size we can say things
like I want the line color for the
circles to be Navy but I want the fill
color to be orange and I want there to
be an alpha on the fill and we can we
can show this result and sure enough we
get exactly that right we get a bunch of
circles that are 15 pixels sort of in
big you know in size big the outline
color is Navy the fill color is orange
and the fill alpha is 0.5 but the
important thing to mention is that you
know I've given fixed values for things
like the color or the size but any of
those values could be given vectors or
arrays of data and then you would get
you know all the all the different
circles would have different sizes or
different colors and we'll see that in a
second so quick exercise why doesn't
everyone try copying and pasting this
code here and instead of size change
that to radius and we'll see what
happens everyone just a second to do
that ok well that's pretty big right so
let's let's maybe change that
okay so again I copied and pasted that I
changed the the size parameter to be
radius and when I do that I get just a
giant you know orange sort of uh you
know thing here but if I if I go ahead
and like zoom out if I if I select my my
wheel zoom tool here and i zoom out we
can sort of get an idea of what's
happened so radius is in screen data
units right so size is always typically
in screen space units and pixels but
radius is usually measured in data units
so this is saying I want a circle that's
15 you know 15 units wide and data space
and so you can see here that sure enough
you know these are all about 15 so let's
change that to something smaller in this
case I'll change it to one in a 1.5 and
and sure enough you can see now we get
circles that are a little bit a bit
smaller but if you can look at the
actual radius sure enough you know this
one starts here at 3 and it goes down to
till 1.5 it has that radius they've
expected and it's also important to note
that the the circles you know they're
their size changes as i zoom in and out
because the radius is in data space the
circles respond and you know the data
space dimension there is preserved
that's different from the size because
I've given the size and pixels if i zoom
in and out these circles don't get any
bigger or smaller they're always going
to have that same screen space size so
there's sort of another important
distinction to consider okay there's a
lot of different markers besides circles
there's you know square things like that
I'm here I'm straightening that you know
as I said if we if we give an array of
values for size then we'll get a bunch
of squares or markers or whatever they
have different sizes right so here I've
given an array of 5 values for the size
and so each of these squares now
responds to that and has a corresponding
size so pretty much any visual attribute
of these glyphs of these markers can be
tied to data in that way they're a whole
lot of them things like you know circle
the circles with you know X's and
crosses triangles all of these these are
just the standard markers there's some
other glyphs we'll talk about in
addition to the markers in just a second
okay so let's try plotting some
different markers I'll give everyone
here just a second to do that sort of
play around with this just going to copy
and paste the code maybe we'll do circle
X and we'll give it things like
line color equals fire brick and fill
color equals I have all these have all
these fun CSS colors that I like using
let's make that even fill alpha equals
three right so so here I've added a new
marker circle X and again you can see
that I can specify things like the line
color independently of the fill color
and again those could also be a rays of
data if you want to have everything
colored differently that's perfectly
fine to do okay line plots obviously
line plots are something you probably
want to do so there's a line glyph very
easy P dot line again you give an array
or a list of x coordinates and Y
coordinates you can give it properties
things like line width and you can see
the plot will respond to that if I say
line width equals 4 you know that's
great or I can say something like alpha
or line alpha equals 0.3 and and now
it's got an alpha value so it very sort
of straightforward to get the sort of
appearance you want out of your plots
their images another one that's pretty
interesting
I'm going to go into too much detail
about this you can see some other
examples this one uses numpy most of the
examples have tried to make so they
don't rely on numpy or anything like
that but this one does a little bit we
actually create an array of RGB values
so red green blue values for the image
and so we set you know ramped a bunch of
red values and a ramped a bunch of I
think blue values there and then we can
pass this to the image RGB a glyph and
that will give us an image right so that
gives us the ability to display images
right so that's pretty nice as well
some other kinds of glyphs again we're
not gonna go into a lot of detail about
these things like rectangles and ovals
obviously those can be you know rotated
and scaled segments and rays so segments
are you know line segments that have two
end points that you specify rays you can
give a single end point and have it
extend off into the distance wedges and
arcs annular wedges those kinds of
things are all available there's some
specialized curves bezzie a and
quadratic curves occasionally get used
just recently
someone added an ellipse as well so
ovals are actually drawn using bezzie
A's and someone added a true ellipse
curve in there we're going to probably
be adding a V bar and H bar primitive
clips as well very soon so we'll give
everyone just a minute to play around
with this trying some examples in the
users guide so if you go to the user's
guide again and go up to users guide and
plotting with basic lifts you can
actually see a lot more examples that
are here in the notebook and so you can
pick any of these and sort of play
around with things you can always have
nice inline plots as well with the code
that generated them so I'll pick one
here just pick some some rectangles
those are probably pretty useful
total output file
okay
it's a definite let me know if anyone
has questions as you try things out in
this case I just plotted some rectangles
but you could imagine plotting whatever
cliff you want that's useful rectangles
again take X values Y values you can
give them a width and a height you can
specify the color which it color by the
way is just a shorthand for line color
and fill color at the same time and same
thing for alpha alpha just is a
shorthand for giving the line alpha and
the Philadelphia together so I could I
could explicitly say you know fill color
equals this and then you know line color
equals the same thing and that would be
equivalent if I want to give both it at
one time I can just say color and so
it's just a it's just a little bit of a
shorthand convenience so change that
back okay okay last thing here is that
it's really easy to draw a multiple
glist together so we've seen drawing one
sort of glyph at a time with this
interface but it's very easy to just
draw multiple ones you just add more
glyphs right so here I've got some data
I want to draw lines and circles on the
same plot so I just called P dot line
with my X my data a P dot circle however
I want that to look and then I I call it
and sure enough I've got lines in
circles right so very easy to make sort
of line charts with these markers on
them or whatever you'd like
whatever combinations you want maybe for
a more complicated example just right
quick to show I'll go over to the
gallery that's also another thing to
point out here the galleries really
useful we're hoping to expand this quite
a bit in the next coming month or two
but it's already got quite a lot of
examples here you know you can see this
color scatterplot and here's sort of a
really interesting example that shows a
lot of different a lot of different
kinds of things together so this has got
obviously very great mini glyphs you
know rectangles and circles and texts
and annular wedges here if you scroll up
you can see pretty much all those glyphs
represented you know rectangles and
wedges and texts and lines and that sort
of thing so okay alright so that's the
plotting interface again very quick sort
of review close that notebook any
questions about that before moving on to
styling
okay so then the next section is just
about how do we customize all of these
things right so how do we make them look
differently there's definitely a lot
more information in the users guide but
let's go through some of the examples
that are here in the tutorial and and
and practice a bit as well so again we
want standard sort of inputs I'm gonna
use poke it out plotting excuse me for
all of these examples so I import from
that I run output notebook and I can see
that Bocage yes is loaded there's a few
notes here that you can read sort of at
your leisure about colors and properties
basically there's a lot of different
ways to specify colors in boquete you
can give the CSS color names RGB a hex
values to pools things like that and
then also some words about what we call
properties right so basically I
mentioned bokeh has all of these objects
that represent everything the plot might
have things like a glyph align glyph for
a circle glyph or an axis or grid and so
they have what we call properties so
things like the line you know line color
line alpha line width those are line
properties fill color fill alpha those
are the filled properties and these are
typically just attributes on those
objects that you can set to have
whatever value you want and so we'll see
a lot of examples of that here in this
section so first thing let's create a
plot I just see that we can modify some
properties of the plot right so here I
create a plot using figure I give it a
plot width and a plot height but I can
also say things like outline width
equals seven and outline line alpha
equals zero three and outline line color
equals Navy and sure enough the outline
of the plot itself has those attributes
but I change the values and the
appearance of that outline by setting
those property values so the exercise
here everyone just to a minute to try
things out is you can you know copy and
paste this code and you can sort of
change things however you might want you
could give something like an outline
line - Peter outline -
- or you can also give it a list of
numbers for the dashing we can maybe
change never change the color of my
favorite fire brick maybe even change
the Alpha to 0.7 they make it a little
bit thinner and sure enough now I get
this nice dashed outline right so I like
y'all play around with that a little bit
if you'd like to but again we're setting
the properties on this plot object to
change its visual appearance the things
that are actually drawn inside the plot
these circles again those are referred
to as glyphs and we can affect their
visual properties as well in fact we've
already done so in the previous section
when we called something like peat
circle and they said lion color equals
red fill alpha equals zero - we're
actually setting the values of these
properties when we call the you know
call that glyph function but it's
possible if you if you get a hold of a
glyph to actually set them you know as
attributes on the object and so the
easiest way to do that is when you call
something like P dot circle it returns
what's called a glyph renderer and then
you can get the glyph off of that and
set its fill alpha its line color its
line - its line width right so here
let's take a look at what I've actually
set I've said our glyph size equals 50
and so these are big nice 50 pixel
circles I've set the fill alpha to 0-2
and sure enough that's fairly
transparent I've set the line color to
fire brick and the line dashing is equal
to the sort of long - short space
dashing and I've set line width equals
to two and so I can if I get ahold of
this clip I can set these property
attributes on the glyph and that's
another way that I can control the
visual appearance
that's especially useful because there
are other types of glyphs on this glyph
render there's this R glyph but there's
also something called the selection
glyph and the non selection glyph and I
can use these to control how things look
when they're selected and so let's take
a look first and then maybe I'll say a
few words so what do I mean by that well
bokeh has a lot of tools that can do
things like selections like a lasso tool
or a box selection tool or this tap tool
that I've added which means if I click
on something that it'll select it and I
can control the visual appearance of
what those selections look like in this
case I've said I want the selection
color when something is selected I
wanted to be firebrick but when it's
when it's not selected when there's a
when there's a selection active I want
the things that are
select it to look like this I want the
fill color to be gray and the Alpha to
be you know 0-2 and so we can see them
sort of grayed out let's go ahead and
change that I changed this line alpha to
0.3 and I can change something like the
non-selection line - equals dashed right
I do here
- oh maybe we can't control the line -
from here I didn't know that okay so you
can control I guess you can just control
the the fill and the colors in the alpha
of these mostly but that's anyway that's
the point is you do have control over
that I'm here I'm hitting the shift key
to do a multi-select but again all the
all the things that are selected have
this you know this policy that I
specified up here where everything is
firebrick and everything that's not
selected gets you know gets this policy
sort of right here and if there's no
selection active it-- the escape key it
just gets the default right so the
default color is just sort of this blue
color and that's you know whenever
there's no selection active that's just
how all of the glyphs are gonna be drawn
one more thing to mention about that is
there's also the notion of a:hover so we
have a hover tool that allows it sort of
do inspections and you can also
configure what the appearance of hovered
glyphs look like as well so there's this
dot hover glyph on the renderer and so I
can change things for it in the same way
with plotting I can give you know hover
alpha and hover line color and so if we
take a look at that this example here
what it's done I've combined it with a
hover tool and now as soon as I you know
as soon as the glyph is hovered it
changes to that hovered appearance and
so this is again just a way of styling
it's a little bit more sophisticated in
advance but there's more information in
the user guide but I do want to make a
point at least show that this sort of
thing is possible I guess we could go
ahead and let everyone spend a few
minutes although we're running a bit
behind where I'd like to be so Mexico
would move on there's an exercise here
if you'd like to just you know create a
plot and sort of play around setting
these different properties you could
again just copy and paste the the code
up here I sort of play around with that
but I'll let you do that on your own
time let's go ahead and keep moving
because there's quite a bit of material
to go through other things that we can
style very well
things like axes and the grids right so
our bokeh dot plotting figures come with
a default you know axis and if all grids
and and they sort of you know make a lot
of sense but we might want to customize
what they look like and so all of those
axes and grids have all these properties
things like you know the axis labeled
but also the you know the major label
text color right that's the color of the
the font that's used to write the labels
under the tick marks all of these
different properties
you know they have like the major tick
you can change the color of the ticks
you can the minor tick marks you can
change the line properties of those how
far they extend into the plot how far
they extend out of the pot there's a lot
of sort of knobs and dials you can you
can turn if you really want to to
customize things the easiest way to get
a hold of the axis to to make you know
to make these configurations is on plots
there is a dot axis attribute and if you
can say 'pete access it gives you back a
list of all the axes but it's actually
what we call this splatter bull list
it's just it's nice that you can you can
say P dot axis and then set an attribute
on it and it will set the attribute for
all of the axes at once right so in this
case let's see in the actual example
here I call figure I pass in some x and
y values for the X marker I give it a
size aligned with but then I say P dot y
axis I want to give the the major label
orientation to be PI over 4 and I want
the major major label orientation of the
y axis to be vertical and sure enough
now the x axis labels are rotated by PI
over 4 radians and then the the y axis
orientation has been set to vertical
this example the next example here does
quite a few more customizations to the
axis right so we can take a look at what
it actually does here I'm using the
asterisk marker so I'm getting asterisks
sort of scattered around my my plot but
I want to change the label to
temperature 4 and the label to pressure
4 y axis I want to change the line width
and the line color to 3 and red for the
x axis okay that's big bold x axis for
the y axis we changed the text color and
the label orientation is servin F we
have orange labels that are oriented
vertically and then finally for the x
axis or for all the axes we want to
maybe change the tick and so we say we
give a negative value for tick in which
means it doesn't actually extend into
the plot actually starts outside the
plot and then the tick out is even
bigger than that and so now we can see
the tick marks actually are outside of
the axis there so we have a really very
fine control over customization of the
way the plot looks if you you know if
you need to sort of exert that sort of
customization you absolutely can do that
all right so I'll let everyone copy and
paste in this example and sort of play
around and change some of these add some
different properties so we'll just take
a minute to do that this here
two holes
okay so I just made a couple of small
changes here I'll talk about a mall
while you guys work I just changed some
of the the minor tic parameters here
instead of having the tics sort of be on
the outside I have them now on the
inside so I changed minor tic in to be
six pixels in and then the minor tic out
is actually minus three pixels out of
the plot so that's actually inside the
plot and I change the color red it's
probably kind of hard to see but if you
look at it you can see that the little
minor ticks are red and now they're all
inside the plot so again really
completely customizable in terms of what
what you want to do any questions about
that first yeah oh yeah so the question
is about can we customize the the ticks
don't have these even numbers yeah so
we'll get to a little bit more about
that maybe later and I can point you the
documentation but the way the the axes
work is they have something that's
called a ticker which is something that
determines where the ticks should go and
there is also a tick for matter which
determines what the format of the the
labels should look like and so there's
some built-in ones that let you specify
you know I want a date time sort of nice
ticking across state scales or I want to
do a single interval ticking or you can
just give it a fixed set of values so
it's very customizable there's several
that are built in and you can go and see
that in the users guide
but yeah so by default there's just sort
of this nice ticker that works across
scale so if i zoom in and out you know
you can sort it picks what are called
you know quote-unquote nice numbers
which are basically multiples of two
five or ten and it just sort of
automatically does that but if you want
to have finer control you can specify a
custom custom ticker yeah okay good
question okay moving on quickly you only
go through this really quickly maybe
just to show some things the the
gridlines exactly the same have these
properties we can use P dot X crude or P
dot y grid to get the actual
corresponding grids out in this case I'm
saying the X grid I don't want to be
there at all so the X grid is the grid
that intersects the x-axis I don't want
to be there to also I just set the line
color equal none but I want the Y grid
to have a line alpha no line dashing and
so now I had this sort of nice alpha
dashed you know y grid so if that's more
appropriate that's very easy to
accomplish there's also a grid band so
if you want to have filled bands on your
grids that's certainly possible as well
so you can give the the band you know an
alpha and a color basically fill
properties and you'll get these nice
alternating bands
on your plot a little behind time so let
me go ahead and skip last thing I'll
mention is legends legends are also
customizable there's a lot of
information in the user's guide so I'll
sort of defer to that but the way
legends work with the book a top
plotting interface is that you can give
basically a legend parameter so these
glyph functions and that will accumulate
all of the different glyphs that have
the same legend name and it'll draw a
nice legend here for you right so here
there were 2 glyph functions that I
called 3 times sine X and so I can see
that both of them the square and the
line are represented faithfully here in
the legend right so I got a lot more
information about legends in the user
guide but we're running a little bit
behind time so let's see so I think in
order to get things on time I'm gonna go
through the next section interactions
because it's pretty neat
and then probably skip maybe onto the
server thing just to make sure we get to
because I promised that we would cover
that today so let's let's go into the
fourth notebook here for interactions
where the layouts widgets interactions
and then we'll go on to the server so
one thing there's a note here is that
some of the functions that are in this
notebook right now we're going to be
deprecated in the near future we are
doing a complete overhaul of our layout
system our fantastic contributor Sarah
Byrd is working on that it's really
exciting it's gonna be a nice much more
responsive she's really cares about
making things sort of responsive and as
she quotes calls them quote-unquote
Webby and so we're doing a lot of really
heavy work to to make the layout system
much better but as part of that we're
gonna be deprecating some of they'll
still work but they will give you
different warnings in the near future
this will all be done though before the
1.0 release I mentioned okay so in
particular just there's a couple of
different layout to execute the first
view cells here so the first thing they
Mason is that bouquet has this notion of
layouts right so here I've got three
different plots that I create s1 s2 and
s3 with the figure and then what I do is
I put them in this grid plot right and
so a grid plot is something that simply
lays out the plots you know in a grid
that I specified so that's that's really
useful don't need to worry about that I
do want to demonstrate some of the other
layouts as well go down here
so if I instead doovy plot and I put
this in a B plot for vertical plot
doodoo out to our location equals none
doesn't apply to that and also gets
children I call it the right way oh
sorry just give it the plots that I want
to be vertical sorry
brain freeze for a second so right so I
created this veep lot that I imported
and then I call V plot with the
different plots that I want to arrange
vertically and sure enough they show up
in a nice vertical orientation so the
reason we sort of went through this
first is cuz I really want to show that
it's very easy to have all kinds of
linked interactions in boquete plots and
without even having a server right
there's only more things we can do when
we get to the bouquet server but even
without it we can do a lot of stuff in
standalone documents so linkages that
are people interested in or maybe link
panning or we have two plots that can
pan together or if the rain just changed
the other one up responds or linked
brushing and so we can see how we can do
both of these things in bouquets so link
panning is super simple if I want to
have two plots that share ranges I
simply share the ranges between them
right so here when I call figure for s2
I can say something like X range equals
the range from my first plot and the Y
range equals the Y range my first plot
here I call figure and I say X range
equals just the X range from the first
plot and it has its own independent Y
range and we can see that if we execute
this code we get three plots and what
happens if I pan well we can see that
the first two plots are linked in both
dimensions and the last plot is only
linked in the X dimension right because
I've only shared that X rayed so linked
panning in boquete is very easy to
accomplish we just share ranges between
plots that's as simple as it is again it
doesn't require the server anything if
you email this to someone this is just
static HTML with some JavaScript all
those interactions are preserved as well
linked brushing is another really nice
feature that's very easy to spell and
Express in bouquet if I have two two
plots that share a data source then I
get automatically get linked brushing
behavior so link brushing means that
when I make a selection on one the
highlighting shows up on the other so
let me actually my lasso tool there and
sure enough right so if I if I may
a lasso tool and I select the points on
this first plot I can see that the
corresponding points on the second plot
have also been highlighted so that's
called linked brushing and again that's
very easy to express in boquete without
any kind of server anything like that I
just have to share a day to source so in
this case is maybe something a little
new I've actually explicitly created
something called a column data source
it's basically like a panda so it's like
a very cheap pandas dataframe I can
think of it like that it's just a bunch
of named columns it's basically a
dictionary with strings as keys and
arrays as values and so I've given it
exactly that I've given at this data
dictionary where it's got XY x y0 and y1
columns and they just have lists of data
and then I passed that as the the source
for my circles so both of these get the
same data source and then instead of
actually passing the literal values here
for x and y I say I want X to be the X
column and Y to be the y0 column and I
want X to be the X column here and Y to
be the y1 con so I give it the name of
the column that I want to take the
values from and so that's why I get two
different points so the the x values are
the same for both plots but the Y values
here are you know absolute value of x
and then x squared over here and so
that's step I get those two plots but
again we share the data source so the
selections are also shared and so it's
very easy to get that kind of linked
behavior invoking another really nice
interaction that people like a lot is
the hover tool so there's a hover tool
built into bouquet and if we hover over
the dots we can see exactly that right
so the hover tool lets us basically
drill down into our data right so I'll
talk about how this works in a second
let's take a look at an example so
there's that version this is the
standard sort of default built in hover
tool it's also possible to customize the
hover tool with a custom template if you
want something to look very different
and so let's take a look at the code
above to see how this works again I'm
creating my data in a column data source
it's just a dictionary where the the
keys are gonna be these strings X Y and
sort of description and then their
Associated values are just these lists
or arrays of values and then I can
create a hover tooltip and the users
guide had a lot of information about
this but basically you tell it I want to
show a label on the hover tooltip in
this case index X Y and description and
that's exactly what we have here index X
Y and description so that's what these
match
and then you tell it what you want to
show and so for each point that you
hover over I can get the index of that
point just know this is the tenth point
to the thirtieth point or whatever I can
get the X&Y positions and I can get the
value of this description column for
that point and so this is index so this
is the second point it's X&Y position
where the cursor is is there and it's
description to see and so we can see
sure enough 0 1 2 the second point has
this description si and so each of these
points lets me drill down and see sort
of maybe further information about it
there's also this custom hover we're
going to details about that basically
it's a little template kind of like a
ginger template that lets you specify
sort of a custom HTML appearance for
this and and works out really nicely so
there's a lot of information about that
in the users guide as well if we go to
the user's guide and we go to we've got
some tools all right so if we go to
configuring plot tools we can go down to
a lot of information about different
tools we can go down to the hover tool
and there's a lot of information about
the custom tool tip this is what those
templates kind of look like we can give
sort of custom HTML and say that we want
you know the you know we want to show
the description field in here and the
index in this you know and we get a nice
customized plot so we have a lot again a
lot of configurability we can see
exactly what we want to see for the tool
tip okay another thing to mention is the
bouquet plays are quite well with
Jupiter interactor so Jupiter has its
own widget set the the jupiter notebook
has its own we just said and so you can
use bouquet together with jupiter
interactors really well this has also
recently been updated and has some nice
new features the key is this pushed
notebook function so what happens
basically is if i have a bunch of you
know a plot or whatever that I create in
boquete if i change values on that and i
call push notebook then the plot inside
the notebook will update right so
anything that I change will update so
that can be useful for this callback
function for the interactor so let's go
ahead and sort of see a concrete example
pretty much stuff there I create a plot
it's just a sine wave and then I call I
PI widgets so if you aren't familiar
with it I'll just point you what this is
called and you can look up more about it
but this is the interact function
basically you give it a callback
then you give it a bunch of fields and
it automatically creates widgets for you
so here I'm going to give it a list of
functions a list of numeric ranges and
so it's going to create sliders and
dropdowns automatically for me without
me having to I need to install any sense
at all of course kondeh install I
probably wait it's unfortunately may
have to restart I forgot that it's not
installed by default I didn't install it
in this directory so let's let's try
restarting here but I may actually have
to restart my my notebook server
actually start at the top scrolling
there we go
got our thoughts yeah unfortunately I
don't know why it does that but I've
noticed if you don't have AI pi widgets
in install when you start the notebook
server it doesn't actually work so let's
just restart right quick there we go
so again execute down to the bottom and
there we go so now so now we get this
nice set of widgets here and again this
is all part of Jupiter it's given me a
drop down for the you know the list of
explicit you know string values I gave
it for the for the numerical ranges it
gives me sliders and the important thing
to note is that you know if I change
this this slider here then the the
actual plot inside the notebook updates
as well and so I can do sine or cosine
or whatever and the way this works is
again whenever anyone any one of these
widget values changes it calls this
update function which says well if the
drop down is sine I want to compute the
sine and then I want to update the data
in my data source and then I call push
notebook and so that's the magic that
sort of ties this together and this is
what makes it really useful to use in in
the Jupiter notebook all right
Boca has its own widgets though these
are really useful they can be useful in
the notebook but they can also be useful
in book applications which we'll talk
about next so how does that work so for
instance I want to happen to be a slider
and so here I import slider from Boca
modeled widgets and I can just give a
slider a start and value a step size and
I can just show it
and sure enough I have a slider so you
know what is what is that good for we'll
see in a minute how that can actually be
useful but I'll go ahead and let
everyone do an actual exercise if you go
to you know the users guide or the
reference guide you can see how to use a
select a select box let's just make a
select box right quick leave that
see if I remember
whatever one there we go
great so take a look at that again if
you go to the users guide there is a
section I believe adding interactions
yeah there's adding widgets under the
adding interaction sections and so you
can see actually a lot of examples here
with some sample code as well and so I
could direct you to there too to look
for information or you can just look at
what I've done here but this is a maybe
a quick exercise that we can do is to
try to create a select box instead of a
instead of a slider
maybe well you only working I can also
say a few words about sort of good ways
to use the bouquet documentation we have
a fairly extensive users guide at this
point they're certainly still parts that
we want to add more to we also have a
really nice reference guide that's
automatically generated as part of our
build and sort of automated test process
and so it's really always up to date
every time there's a released as I
mentioned all the things that make up a
plot or a visualization are called
models and so basically if you want to
look up what properties anything any
model has you can go under book github
models and you can see there's a bunch
here you know there's layouts and grids
and glyphs and in this case we're
looking at widgets and we want to do a
an input widget so we can look down here
for select I think it's on this page do
deselect there we go class like and so
it'll tell you exactly what it's got
right so it's got this options attribute
which is the list of options that you
want it to be in the Select box as well
as this value property as well which is
whatever the initial the initial value
is probably less interesting but you if
you're really curious you can dig down
into this JSON prototype for what looks
like if you are ever interested in
writing another language binding for
boquete this is for instance what would
be very useful so folks that have
written our bouquet or bouquet top Scala
or bouquet doubt lua they would use this
information to know how to generate the
right jason from those languages but
anyway yeah the reference guide is
really helpful obviously it's helpful if
you can sort of know what you're looking
for already if you know where to sort of
start so the users guide in the
reference guide both complement each
other in that way okay so we go down
here we've got our select box here I
just you know again I imported select I
called select I gave it a value of foo
so that's the initial value and I gave
it these list of options and sure enough
if I look on my select box I can see
those are the options there so I mean
that's great but unless I can do
something in response to the widget
changing it's not too terribly useful so
what can we do this is one area where we
relented or compromised a little bit
sort of I'll say in a minute is that we
added something called a custom JS
callback and basically the custom J's
callback is a concession to the notion
that well you know if you write a little
bit of JavaScript you can actually be
really really powerful things in
standalone documents
so this is a way to sort of inject a
little bit of job JavaScript into your
bouquet documents here's an example I
create this custom j/s object it's got a
code property so I give it a little
snippet of J's code in this case I just
say alert hello world and I attach that
to tap tool and that means if I tap any
of these objects that's gonna forget
what alert right so you can imagine
there's actually a lot of things you can
do with that there's a lot of places in
boquete where you can add callbacks on
widgets any of the widgets basically you
know you click a button you select
something from a drop-down you add type
into a text field you you know move a
slider any of those things can have
these little J's callbacks added to them
tools it's etc if you make a selection
if you do a tap tool if you change the
range on a plot by panning or zooming
you can do callbacks and those happens
as well
so there's a lot of places where you can
inject these little bits of JavaScript
code so let's take a look at a little
bit more sophisticated example here's
one for a widget so this one I've got a
slider and here at the bottom with a
start and an invaluable you I've got
some data here it's just X to the N you
know for some value of N and then my
custom day has call back looks at the
slider gets its value and then it
recomputes a new set of Y values and so
let's see what it looks like first then
we'll take a look at the code right so
I've got my plot I've got my slider and
sure enough if I scrub the slider that's
fun I scrub the slider I can see this
update it again this is not using any
kind of server this is just a standalone
HTML document this would be preserved
you know if you email didn't put it on a
web page it's just serve it statically
this interaction is still preserved
right so there's a lot you can do with
it sort of these custom J's callbacks
and so again it's you know we get our
data we get the value from the slider we
pull out the X&Y columns of the data and
then I just have a loop here that says
math dot POW I just raise X to whatever
value the slider has and then I call
source trigger to tell the plot to
update and so that's my little tiny
snippet of JavaScript that allows that
to happen I will mention though in some
cases it's actually possible to write
that in Python now and have it compiled
to JavaScript where we're living in a
world where more and more things are
compiled to JavaScript so why not Python
too if we go to the user's guide
we can go to adding interactions we can
go to the very bottom and we can see the
same example here but now the callbacks
actually written in Python and this is
compiled is it just to be clear the
Python is not executed it's compiled to
JavaScript and but it still works
exactly the same and so we can see you
know I get the data I get the value from
the slider I get my X&Y fields like I
call a math dot POW and then I call
source not trigger and so that's you
know sometimes useful as well is that we
can just write it in Python and it still
turns into this nice chance callback and
and so this was originally it is part of
booking out yeah so this was largely
written by all mark client who works on
viz by and PI script and so and bouquet
and so this is interesting this was at
first a Python 3 only feature because
that's what he wanted to support we
convinced him that Python 2 was still
you know at least I'm marginally useful
or important news case and so now python
2 is supported as well but he wrote the
PI script library that does this
conversion and it's used in I think flex
he also works on and then that may be
part of the visit by work so but yeah so
it works it works pretty nicely ok great
callbacks for selections here's another
example that's kind of cool let's see
what it does first and then I'll explain
about the code so here I got a lasso
tool and if I actually select a bunch of
points with my lasso tool the yellow
line moves and it shows me where is the
median for all this points or the
average rather so the mean up not the
median so you know if I if I make a nice
little narrow thing here and that's
great if I make sort of a weird you know
shape you know it's gonna do whatever
it's just gonna keep updating right so
it works also with multi-select right if
I if I hit the shift key I can i can do
multi select and it'll update based on
multiple not sure why it's doing that
weird selection anyway so how does the
code that does that what does that look
like so this was a little bit more
involved might be nice to redo this one
in in pi the Python that compiles to
JavaScript but the basic idea is that I
attach a custom J's call back to my
column data source yep
yes that callback equals custom dais and
this callback gets triggered
never a selection is made so anytime any
tool causes a selection to happen on the
data source it will call this callback
and what does it actually do well it
gets the indices of all the selected
points it's gonna get the data it's
going to loop over all of the indices
and then it's going to compute that why
they like right so it says you know
what's the y mean value starts out at
zero it's going to loop over all of the
indices and then it's gonna add you know
the the Y value of the selected points
to this mean it's gonna divide it by the
length of the selected points which
gives you the the actual mean value for
the Y and then it sets the data source
for this yellow line to be that mean
value and then when it calls the the
triggers and that's what actually
happens let's take a look
let me go so that's what it's doing so
again it's as as the selection changes
it recomputes that mean value Y value
with this little loop here in JavaScript
and then it sets the data for that line
to be this this Y value okay so that's
cool so I think we're definitely running
a little behind so now I definitely want
to turn to the server stuff so things
that we're skipping here or at a time
there's some notes about embedding and
sharing plots using the bouquet dot
embed API it's fairly straightforward
you can you know embed these things in
Django or flask applications however you
want there's a section here about models
which is sort of the the lowest level
API it's again I said everything is
really comprised of model is there the
building block layer you know if you can
imagine you got all these sort of ligo
parts that you can put together whatever
you want this is the most verbose sort
of API but it's also the most flexible
it gives you complete and total control
basically over everything and then and
there's also Oh we'll mention another
new feature is that it's possible now to
extend the model system with your own
custom custom models so just to quickly
run through this notebook just to show
what's in here my scroll is behaving
very strangely import the data so this
is reproducing a chart from The New York
Times this started about Usain Bolt's
sort of his Olympic performance and you
know we get this nice hover tool I'm
executing you know that sort of shows
you know what's the person how far
behind are they you know and this is a
nice reproduction of a chart but we're
able to reproduce it so well because
again we're sort of working at this very
low level but you can sort of work
through the example but I did want to
mention that it's possible to make
custom user models and again this is
actually I think nice because this means
that opens up for the floodgates for
users to start experimenting with new
features or new functionality without
having to sort of dive into a full
development environment like you know
developing bouquets a little bit of a
chore to sort of get your environment
set up but now you can do that on a any
release version of ok you can start
developing your own custom extensions
and I think it's gonna hopefully open up
a lot of really exciting sort of
contributors sort of extensions that
maybe users contribute to the library
just as an example we have to create
some JavaScript code to create an
implementation for that but we can
create a new model in this case a
subclass of hbox
and we want to give it this border color
property and what it does that it
creates it styles the CSS box for the
sakes box and using that border color
and so if we just run it the main thing
is just to run it and see what it does
if I run these then sure enough I said
border color equals fire brick if I say
border color equals Navy then it changes
right so I have this customized H box it
has this special behavior and yes it did
require me to write a little bit of
JavaScript so this is extending the this
okay with this JavaScript so this is
something advanced users might do but
I'm really hoping that this allows
people to not have to wait on us right
there's any number of features that
people might ask for want the you know
either we can't get to in time or fast
enough but this is sort of a shortcut
route for people to develop their own
features so you could imagine wrapping
other JavaScript libraries this way so
if you want to have maybe a d3 really
sophisticated d3 projected map that's
actually powered by Python analytics you
could wrap some d3 with them on a custom
model that ties it back to the Python
and I think that's actually a really
compelling use case that I'm gonna try
to work up maybe an example of that
pretty soon okay but i would be remissed
if i don't talk about the server so um
so let's do a little bit about that so
first off to note these exercises really
require working outside the notebook if
you want to follow along that's great
otherwise I'll just go through it pretty
quickly so I mentioned that there's this
notion of the way bouquet is architected
that there are models in Python you know
things for plots and axes and glyphs and
and data sources all those things and
they get mirrored into the browser so
the browser has this same picture of
things so how does that and that's
really useful but what the server can do
and take it to the next episodes of
models synchronized so something changes
on the server the the clients
automatically update if something
changes on the the browser the server
automatically updates and that two-way
communication is really valuable so
let's take a look at an example here
this is just a hello world in in bouquet
so let me go ahead and create a text
file that has that in it so I'm just
gonna use the VI I go here hello dot pi
there we go talk about the code here in
a second and then if I say bouquet serve
- - oh hi I get this nice page and it's
you know the styling is not we're gonna
have anything to style it but I can say
hi and it's just a little bouquet or if
I you know say hello pie data London and
I say hi then it's just a little pie
element right so the application here
anyone that navigates that URL will get
this application that's responsive and
what is the actual code here look like
well so I've got some imports that's
great I create a button but instead say
hi I've create a text input field that
allows me to type in you know whatever I
want I create this output paragraph it
lets me write text to it my update
function just says copy whatever it's in
the output you know whatever is in this
input text box say hello you know with
that and put that in the paragraph and
that's my on click update I put
everything in a layout here I've got
some H boxes and V boxes and then I call
this add route and that's it and then I
call bouquet serve and now I've got this
responsive web application so that's
kind of interesting so that's the
illustrates the core functionality of
tying these Python models to the book
the JavaScript models seamlessly and
transparently and so you can have these
nice applications that you know that
don't that don't require any sort of
talk you have to write a JavaScript to
do that right so yeah this is web page
that has you know widgets and and
responds and calls feith on and you
didn't have to write a lick of
JavaScript to make that work and so I
think that's sort of the point let's see
another example that links plots
together with widgets so here I'm going
to call this app PI a little bit more
involved it's actually hard for me to
there we go so we'll call this app dot
PI I'll copy and paste this so VI app
dot pi let's run it and then we'll talk
talk about it so bouquet serve - show
app dot PI and that opens up another app
and so here I've got a bunch of points
but maybe I want to have more points
right maybe you want to have 2,000
points that's fine
maybe I want to see a different color
let's go to Olive or to goldenrod or you
know whatever and again we could go down
to 20 points now or let's do 10,000
right so all of that works fine and so
again
anyone that sort of navigates to this
you know I'm running a locally on my
machine but you could imagine deploying
this kind of application and there's
lots of ways to do that we have a lot of
extensive documentation on deploying
lokay applications behind apache behind
nginx if you need to scale them out if
you need to you know run them behind
load balancers boko server applications
are very horizontally scalable so
basically you need more capacity
typically you can just run more so it's
really nice in that in that regard and
so we have a lot of documentation about
that in the users guide in terms of how
to deploy a bouquet server but it's very
easy to run things locally like this or
just to serve them you know if you have
a small internal group or network you
can certainly just serve them very
easily just by running bouquets serve
but we also have a lot of information
for more sophisticated cases as well ok
so let's take a look at one more example
here
ok Knox we want to go to server a last
example streaming data we also added
recently this stream method to column
data sources and so that's maybe a cool
one let's take a look at that as well 5
VI stream dot p i stream got pi rather
let's run it and we'll talk about the
code here in a second
so what does this do well it brings me
up a little pot I do oh my miss type
stream is what I did oh right needs a
comment thank you so let's draw
something and it's gonna look this
update right so it's just sort of
updating this streaming data it's
streaming new values to this set of
coordinates to draw these circles out in
a very efficient way so obviously given
the way that we have this sort of
automatic you know synchronization in a
certain sense you could just stream data
just by updating the data source but if
you're if you have a use case where
you're always sort of appending a new
value you know a next value there's a
lot more efficient ways to do that and
this stream API lets you do that
let's take a look at the code what do I
have here for my stream example so I've
got a figure right just like we've been
doing all along I create a circle on
that it's just a big circle with radius
1 I create a new column data source for
those little tiny circles in this case I
start with just one of them and I I
create it and I give it that data source
I have an update function here that
looks at the last whatever the last
little tiny circle is its X&Y
coordinates and then it rotates it so
you don't need to worry about the the
trig stuff here but basically what it
does is it rotates it by a certain fixed
angle and then it streams that new value
into the data source and the way this
works is that new data should be a
dictionary that has the exact same
columns as the column data source you're
streaming to you can give it a rollover
value that tells it how much data to
keep right you don't want the data to
just grow without bound right if I don't
if I don't give this rollover value
which is gonna keep infinitely appending
data so I want to typically give a fixed
rollover value so that you know it
truncates the data at some point let's
give it a different one let's give it
excuse me give it rollover I don't know
anyone have a suggestion we have it
rollover equals 18 and let's change this
periodic call back and so we also added
a periodic call back here that says how
often you know how often should this
call back be run and so I lowered it
down to 50 milliseconds and we can see
it's a lot faster and now there's more
I've kept more of the data by by
increasing that rollover value and so
again this is a really fairly efficient
way to do that let me show just
demonstrate some other ones that are
built into the examples here right quick
just to to show things off definitely
running out of time under examples app
there's quite a few examples here if I
do this is a fun one this OLC chart
right so this is a chart that's
generating synthetic data you know
return data you can imagine it's also
creating computing the MACD indicator
down here several indicators it has some
widgets at the top that let me control
the simulation maybe I want to have a
you know much higher mean or I want to
have a wider variance I can also control
what kind of moving average you know a
different tick I can move this around I
can tell it to start resetting to the
the updating okay so I've got this nice
web app how many lines of code would you
expect to have to write huh I can't do
ten yeah you have to go hard then but
including including the actual code to
generate the data the simulation itself
and the code to do it this was less than
a hundred lines of Python code right so
that's including the the fake data
generation
right the and so that I think it's
pretty cool to get is a sort of
streaming deployed well location without
much or any JavaScript in this case
another one we have this nice movies
clone here it's kind of a little cross
filter tool lets me sort of say hey I
want to filter by the number of dollars
at the box office you know or I want to
see different genres or things that were
only released before you know two
thousand nine or how many Oscars it has
to have one a certain number of Oscars
and you know I've got this nice hover
tool let me drill down so this is if
this is familiar there was an are shiny
example that's very similar to this one
that we sort of a used as inspiration we
also added though I think a nice touch
the the Razzie Award winner so we can
see that how much money a film makes is
not necessarily correlated with whether
or not wins a Razzie anyway so that's
another example okay so that's the
server had actually hoped to say a bit
more about that I got behind on time but
quick questions about that before I
pivot to one last topic and then maybe a
few questions any questions now though
okay so the streaming as I said when you
use the streaming API it only sends the
new values which is why it's a lot more
efficient again if you specify you know
if you don't specify rollover he just
sort of cumulating data in the client
which is eventually not going to work
especially if you're updating quickly we
do have other plans to add for instance
some binary array protocol so all the
communication with the bookie server is
now done through WebSockets and much
sort of more robust WebSocket protocol
but it's still doing basically JSON all
the things and so we're gonna add some
transparently some binary array
protocols it should actually improve the
performance there even more but it's
already quite you know quite robust so
yeah okay well let me pivot a little bit
I have a couple of slides here for
something called a new project it's
under the bokeh organization it's called
data shader let me just say a couple of
words and maybe show a quick example so
this is something that we had originally
wanted to put sort of in boquete and
then we realized that it really could be
a separate sort of project it's sort of
a pipeline for data visualization that
we could hook up to bouquet and maybe
they'd be better for both projects if
things were separate and so there's now
a new project called bouquet data shader
it's headed up by Jim Bednar who used to
work with university Edinboro he's in
Austin now works a continuum and he's
sort of heading up this effort so you
know bouquet is really nice because we
can sort of pass this data to it and a
very easy way from high-level and it
works pretty well you know into the tens
of thousands maybe even the hundreds of
thousands of points you know we have
some nice features for level of detail
down sampling for instance if you're
panning it'll only show a fraction of
the point so that the panning stays
responsive but you know eventually if
you you know you don't want to send a
billion points in the browser ie but you
could you wouldn't want to do that
partly because the you know just you run
into visualization problems not even
technology problems if you if you try to
do a scatter plot of a billion points
you get over plotting and you know you
can't see any the data that you want to
see and so it's not very useful and so
data shader is about building
visualization pipelines that can sort of
mitigate these problems of you know
understand over plotting under plotting
and all of these sorts of things and so
there's this big pipeline architecture
I'm not gonna go into details basically
it does a we imagine sort of a synthetic
rendering of the data and then the nice
thing about this step is that it can be
very easily paralyzed and so we actually
done that with the desk library as well
the open source task library and then
the resulting aggregate can be sent to
the browser and you can still do a lot
of interesting transformations on the
aggregates but the key is that those
transformations are very fast so here's
an example of the New York City Taxi
data set this was done with ten million
you know ten million data points in this
so this sort of reveals the entire data
set if I actually go down into a
notebook and have it running here we go
got New York City Taxi running in here
so this is this is the New York City
Taxi data setting you can see this
notebook in the repo but we've basically
added some visual query steps too so
data shader also has these nice sort of
visual currie things I want to shade
areas where you know pickups are greater
than drop-offs you know sort of blue and
where the converse is true I want to
shade them red and so we can sort of see
the structure here and obviously in
Manhattan you know it's not too
surprising major streets and
thoroughfares are where the pickups
happen the drop-offs happen on these
cross streets and because we know about
Manhattan we know that these big
vertical avenues are the major streets
but what's kind of interim we don't know
what that we don't have that same grid
structure but we can infer that now
because we have you know this
information we can actually shade the
data we can infer what are the major
streets here in Brooklyn this by the way
is now
updating the full ten million point
dataset right so this is actually
running on my laptop so as i zoom in you
can get two levels of progressive
refinement you can get to the level
where you start to see individual
measurements right progressively refined
there's some really cool things you can
see I was like to zoom over here in the
Javits Center so there's a big giant
conviction center here on the west side
of Manhattan called the Javits Center
has this big circular parking lot in
front and you can see the taxis come in
and they drop people off and they
medially pick people off and come out I
think it's kind of cool but you can see
all these sort of pattern of life kind
of you know pattern of life kind of
things sort of start to emerge from the
days that's when you can ask these kind
of questions and this kind of visual
shading this this you know this this
kind of shading here this is the fast
part you know you can sort of ask these
questions until it's update those those
things very quickly another one just to
show off another example this is I think
how many data points is this this is
only a million data points but it's it's
a it's a trajectory X Y points looks
fairly straightforward but if we zoom in
we see that it's actually got a wiggle
at a finer scale all the way through and
if we zoom in further yet we actually
see that there's been noise added at the
smallest scale and so the question is
can we actually be able to sort of look
at this in a dynamic way and again with
data shader you know I can zoom into
this here and I can start to see
progressive refinement and I can get
into the detail at any area of the plot
sort of as fast as I want and so this
again is the data shader project it's
pretty new definitely you know is it the
stage where you know people coming in
and taking a look at it and banging on
it giving really good feedback is what
will help move the project along even
further so I encourage anyone to have
sort of requirements there to look at
data shader a few more slides here and
I'll let you go
lost my too many too many windows open
there we go just an example for
processing really large scale data you
know this is the OpenStreetMaps data set
is about 3 billion gps coordinates you
know if you have the RAM that's great
data shader process this in seven
seconds on an ec2 with 120 28 gigs of
RAM but the thing is you can actually do
out of core computations as well because
this is powered by tasks which can do
out of course scheduling
you could do this on your Mac in fact
Jim did that I forget how long it took
obviously since the data set won't
actually fit in memory it takes quite a
bit longer but you know on the order of
maybe minutes to process 3 billion
points on your Mac as opposed to much
longer so anyway that's that's the
shading of that the sense of state is
another nice example I don't have it
running here with me but it's cool
because this is fairly novel is that you
can have all these data so this is 300
million points the US Census but it's
tagged by self selected racial category
and so you can actually have data shader
combine these in more sophisticated ways
right if you just plotted all the points
plots would stack up on top of one
another you would have over plotting
problems you wouldn't be able to see but
because of the way the data shader
pipeline operates it can actually modify
and merge these and much more sort of
efficient and visually efficacious ways
and then if you zoom in again you get to
the level where you start to see
individual dots for the individual
measurements of the census and it's
pretty nice anyway these are things that
sports currently time-series heat maps
trajectories that sort of thing a lot of
examples here I think they're looking at
some of the uber data set is maybe one
of these and you know this is some of
the census data set there's a quite a
few interesting things and a lot of
examples in the in the repo so check it
out
contents all data shader it's on github
as well under the bouquet organization
and there's several notebooks up on and
I found about order as well so apologies
I didn't get to do quite as much
hands-on stuff for the servers I'll be
here to be here most of the weekend
please come by and ask me questions and
be happy to talk about ok or any other
open source projects any last-minute
questions before we adjourn yes
yeah so the question is what are some
alternatives to bouquet and there's you
know there's an endless number basically
you know plotting tools obviously in the
Python space matplotlib is is a
fantastic libraries been around a long
time one area where I live currently as
a you know a definite advantages if you
need static output like programmatically
generated SVG's pngs
hands down MATLAB is gonna be what you
want for now we are working on adding
SVG output to bouquet and also making
that programmatically available you know
beyond that I would say sort of a toss
up if you want to deploy something to
the web
definitely bouquet I think is maybe a
good place to start especially if you
want to be able to have these sort of
server applications right I mean all
that infrastructure is just built-in it
sort of takes away the burden of having
to write the client-server architecture
and having to write a lot of JavaScript
and so it's really nice other libraries
obviously to mention we also have some
level of matplotlib compatibility it's
not complete we use a third-party
library that only handles some things
but it you know it gets a fair amount
done if you're coming from are obviously
you might be inclined to look at like
ggplot and people love that I will say
there's an are binding for bouquet that
Ryan - is created so you can go to our
bouquet and you can see all these spots
these are generated by our these are
bouquet plots but generated from our
code and so I'm actually not you know I
I don't have use are in a good twenty
years dating myself but uh you know the
ggplot is really fantastic
I think bouquet is pretty cool too and
so again I think might be a sort of a
toss up there I know people are working
to make our bouquet and a great for
instance with shiny really well HTML
widgets and beyond that there's things
like D 3 d3 is also a really wonderful
library but it's also a JavaScript
library so you really have to want to
start from JavaScript it's sort of I
considered it maybe an artisanal tool
you can make these amazing sort of you
know Sarah would say webby you know
responsive just beautiful graphics but
you got to put a fair amount of effort
into it right and you've got to work
from JavaScript and and deal with a lot
of CSS and HTML and SVG and and all this
javascript nib relation and so we're
trying to we're trying to sort of back
away from that a little bit and maybe we
sacrifice a little bit of the web you
sort of responsiveness but we're trying
to get to that 90% use case where people
can do more with less code right that's
that's the sweet spot we're trying to
hit if I said something in general
beyond that there's other certainly
commercial products you know there
things like plotly and tableau and i
charts and you know they are all have
their own uses and advantages as well so
they're just a matter of does it fit
your particular need so I know if that
answer question hopefully some of that
was useful but yeah one more question so
we want to we want to converge and
integrate that with that really well I
mean part of the as everything we're
working on a lot of sort of automated
layout improvements right now and so
part of that I think will fall out into
bouquet apps the ones that I
demonstrated here you know writing a
little bit of Python code in terms of
like a higher level you mean like a tool
for creating dashboards like a visual
dashboard creation
maybe yeah that's a little bit further
down the road but we're certainly
interesting that in the effort that's
going into Jupiter workbench into
Jupiter dashboards there's a lot of
interesting places where we can connect
and converge there absolutely writing
dashboard is something that we're being
able to create a nice dashboard
something eat as easily as possible
something we're interested in furthering
so yeah stay tuned I guess is money yes
okay well I think I've it's right at
noon so I think that's the stopping
point but I thank everyone for for
coming I hope it was useful and feel
free to come and find me anytime over
the weekend